do you know what I miss go girls a visco
girl is a hyper rad girl who cares about
the earth but is also super approachable
and definitely not in it for social
media followers all right
genuine and kind of the ideal that we as
humans should aspire to me mm-hmm right
exactly correct like I'm like a fiscal
you are let's go girl am i dating of
this go girl oh my god I'm doing so much
better for the planet than I thought I
would just by dating you know pie makers
for some people life is different now I
went on Twitter and I asked the age-old
question for this old aged woman what is
a disco girl because that is what is
trending right now you know me I love to
keep up with the trends and the high-end
and the the youths vsco I don't know if
it's an acronym if you had to make an
anachronism what would it be video sucks
colors off am I good yeah I'm good
though vagina
scrub cooter ouch
virgins suck a lot of people are
transforming themselves into visco girls
because we all love to conform to a
cult-like quality of person that is not
fully representative of the ideals and
values that we hold as individual beings
because I love a bandwagon I love
jumping I'm gonna get on this bandwagon
and I asked you guys to give me some
guidelines as to how I can properly jump
on and it has been an interesting
response to my tweet about in the
briefest way possible what of this go
girl is one I received a response
without the puck and this just this
photo yes stuck the Pug is a visco girl
it's like Billy Eilish but
as a bug Billy Eilish got dresses like a
$20.00 gas station challenge here are
some actual responses Jeep long shirt or
sweater hydro flask and tins of
scrunchies simply shown necklace hydro
class Birkenstocks oversized t-shirt
friendship bracelets messy buns glossy a
scrunchies what's a Hydra what
hydroflax I believe hydro meaning water
in a flask meaning concealed object and
which liquor goes into its where you put
your water into put the water in plastic
these girls because they care about
themselves in the environment skinny
girls wearing clothes that fat girls get
called from peon teenager version of a
white mom and yoga pants isn't this
normcore normcore plus grungees
scrunchies oversized t-shirts
puka-shell necklace hydro glass with
stickers I'm going to look up what a
hydro flask is you can get 20% off your
hydro flask at Moose Jaw calm for any
adventure three people those I mentioned
are double wall vacuum insulated if
there's one thing I've always said about
water it's that it should be more like
hood it should be imprisoned in a
container in prison than a food like
container everyone's saying as KS KS KS
KS k and what's and I love you what is
this is 666 people know and I hope is
from where well Jackson it seems like
it's mostly scrunchies oh no these girls
sound complicated and exhausting and
I'ma see one presentational earth
consciousness and they're pushing the
capitalist machine is that the direction
you want to go with your channel they
are maybe create they are existing in a
world where they are perpetuating the
systems that you're destroying things
are trying to save supposedly should I
donate and then go to Burlington Coat
Factory and see if I can figure out this
is better as long as you Instagram a
little time you know Bisco care sorry
yes I'm gonna try my best to create a
disco girl aesthetic do you think you're
up for this absolutely then I didn't
hear exactly what you said but I'm
totally
and wasn't even to me this complaining
you know yeah sure well you can't but I
don't I mean yeah what I found it like
this is it right it's amazing that these
Crocs are just sitting here in Elliott's
exact no no no no I don't want that's
pretty good that might be it yeah how
are you feeling bad about all of your
treasures really good I think we were
really strong out there good defense I
would change
my awareness we made it bad I have
treasures it's been all 43 minutes now
I'm going to show you my Cinderella
moment the one bummer is I couldn't find
a puka shell necklace so I took my Ross
Dress for Less receipt and I just
wrapped it around my neck
got all the scrunchies on the friendship
bracelets with basically scrunchies for
friendship bracelets the shoes that are
weirdly comfortable I got my hydro flash
they love hydro clasp with stickers I
did not get stickers but I did have a
new bathing suit that I tried on
yesterday and I took this sticker out of
like the cooter lining of it and then I
put that on the hydro flask so there is
disgusting the worst it's hot in an
infant alized way yeah this is like a
little girl got loose in her dad's
closet like what happens if my daddy
issues I wear them on my body yep right
down south obviously we have the world's
most comfortable socks new socks that
really likes that this is a hydro class
but I filled it with beer overflowed and
spilled up a lot of my belongings I
don't know why this is a little bit
attractive this is now a very weird week
I hope we did this in a way that was
entertaining I don't know that we came
up with any sort of conclusive results
on anything but we got out of the house
I don't know I don't know if I like this
hey you guys are watching like we don't
in the comments below what you think the
next type of person them will be in the
future then mo venmo girl what's a venmo
girl look like should we start that
subscribe to this youtube channel i make
videos yeah whenever described a helia
over on ballet folk and on his channel
Elliott Morgan and other than that I
don't know okay before this video ends i
have to thank audible for sponsoring
today's video and i think i've actually
become a fiscal girl and i don't know
how i feel about it you have the world's
largest selection of audio books and
audio entertainment including audible
originals or stories that are created
exclusively at for audio we're talking
documentary exclusive audiobooks and
scripted josie can't hear anywhere else
and now if you become an audible member
you get more than ever you can choose
one audiobook and two audible originals
every month and members get access to
exclusive guided fitness and meditation
programs you have no excuse not to feel
good and i'm gonna tell you about my
friends new foe lisa schwartz you guys
know we're probably has a youtuber
comedian and actress and she's just a
great human being and she's got a new
book called 30 life crisis and not only
as an in book form it's an audiobook
form on audible she reads it Congrats
lisa 30 life crisis navigating my
thirties one drunk baby shower at a time
the forward is by shane dawson and then
what more could you want so you guys
start listening with a 30 day audible
trial you choose one audiobook and two
audible originals for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium pletely for free
by going to audible.com/veritasium grace
- 500 - 500 I gotta go save a turtle
Skeet Skeet Skeet Skeet
they're the ones that seem like they're
hipper than everyone else but no one is
super than anyone else the people that
are hipper than everyone else
of the ones that are trying to Harvin
till they're exhausted like fashion it
goes from the top times like when you
see extreme fashion like yeah on the
runways and it trickles down like how
they say a double Wears Prada but it
becomes what we actually wear it's like
the hyper version of hips that trickles
down but they're there they're creating
it they're forcing it and then from that
it will have an effect on all of us and
we will all be physical girls in the end
you don't miss go boys okay you've seen
Devil Wears bottle I haven't seen it
long back yeah do you think great movie
yeah